so what you have to do is get a baby
lotion they sort of cover themselves
and it actually adds about four to five
ml of girth because it's thick it's like
icing a cake so you're icing yourself
and if you move slowly you've just got
this long non-blue because it's covered
in cream member
[Music]
a friend of mine was a dj club and he
said uh look
they've got dancers here they've got
this male troops every saturday night
you're pretty confident with your body
300 women queued up outside so you know
you take the top off i'm then getting
more excited they're getting excited
more clothes are coming off
and i did the first performance ever
they just literally run the track
next minute i'm naked on a stage
flashing everyone and yeah it felt
incredible
okay tricks of the trade so um
you do the press-ups because it just
fills the muscle with blood gives you a
pump
you just get more of a fuller physique
from it and it will stay there for a bit
the old school ones
uh with sort of the generic mouth
stripping side the first thing is tying
off a guy called carl warlock legend
carl showed me just there he goes right
just and he popped his trousers down and
he's like right you just need to you
know
get her house yeah you take an elastic
band double it up but essentially
you're cutting off the circulation that
retains i would say 78
the size you don't want to get it do it
early that's rookie school boy new boy
stuff
you don't want to do it too late because
then they're like please welcome
so everyone has you know a huge
confidence on stage they all think it's
fake anyway so what you have to do is
get a
baby lotion they sort of cover
themselves and it actually adds about
four to five ml of girth
because it's thick it's like icing a
cake so you're icing yourself
and if you move slowly you've just got
this long non-blue because it's covered
in cream
member because the next guy's doing it
the guy before you said you're not going
to not do it then i can tell you
anything our fire out was performing
um his routine and he does an incredible
it's called a bow staff
and he spins it around it goes
everywhere and it's got eight pieces of
fine
fire wick on it spinning around at a
rate you would not believe all the girls
going
oh he's like oh yeah like this is great
and the next minute someone's
i'm side of stage it was like he's on
fire so i literally grabbed the wet
towels from the side of stage
and i just put him out he had no idea
thank god he wasn't hurt i mean
he lost his teacup plate of hair and was
really it was actually really bad
blessing me it's fine now i wanted to
entertain i had a space to entertain and
a platform in the early days i used to
rock up to gigs and i had a portable
shower i had a silhouette screen and
then these other guys would just rock up
with some black baby oil and a banana
and they think oh yeah they just need a
hot guy to take his clothes off women
will go wild
yes they'll go world my dad could go on
stage and they'll go wild
i know women want more what is sexual
what is
fantasy based what is fulfillment the
show i created was the sexy circus and
that in my opinion is the
evolution of the industry so we get you
know
beautiful guys inside and out no egos
who have spent their life training
on a live stream that would be
acrobatics serial
aerial fire these incredibly talented
skills
and then they also happen to be in great
shape and again the nudity for me is
revealing and ruining the fantasy of
what and what if you want what you can't
have
so we say no going home with the girls
after the show
because it takes all of that away from
everyone and it's their night you get
you've got
this is your job not your night this is
their night
we did a show in belfast at the
waterfront and we sold 1800 tickets
i felt like a i was in a boy band me and
the boys were there we were like this is
so crazy like you can't
eighteen hundred people screaming at you
it's mind-blowing and it's incredible to
be a part of everyone's in a good mood
you're in a good mood everyone's happy
you're happy everyone's excited you're
excited people come to us to
to just let loose and have fun and to be
a part of that is a blessing and it's
incredible i love it
people have no idea the love the passion
the effort
put into being on stage how proud they
are being on stage and
costume choreography their physique what
they have to go for on a weekly basis to
get that high
uh for you know a few hours a few nights
a week people just go oh stripper they
just drop their level of expectations
they're so
shocked that you're normal and you're
not just trying to have sex with them oh
well i thought you just took your
clothes off you know you can sort of be
in this industry i'd say
realistically from your early 20s if
you're lucky mid-30s but really by then
you know you kind of want to be moving
on if you're smart enough to use that
capital that's free time and graft
you can create whatever life the life of
your dreams i love it because i've
created a business so i'm always going
to be involved but if i didn't create my
business would i still be into it
it's very difficult thing it's a
wonderful thing to be a part of but
you know you hear the crowd screaming
you know your pole starts racing and
you're about to go live
you know and they go right so it starts
off you go
you